اقليم كاراباخ بيد اذربيجان بمباركه موسكو
خلال 24 ساعه فقط حسم الصراع بين اذربيجان
وارمينيا وهو بعض من ارث الحقبه السوفيتيه
فعلى مدى ثلاثه عقود تواجهت الدوله في
جولات قتال اعقبت سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي
داخل ارمينيا تم 8 يرى ان مصير اقليمي
كاراباخ كان محسوما منذ هزيمه ارمينيا في
حرب خريف 2020 التي استمرت 44 يوما وخلافا
لجوله القتال السابقه فان اللافت هذه
المره ان اذربيجان احكمت سيطرتها على
الاقليم ونزعت سلاح الجماعات الانفصاليه
من ارمن كاراباخ دون اي مقاومه عمليه تذكر
من الحكومه الارمينيه برئاسه نيكول
باشنيان وان طويت صفحته كاراباخ واخرج من
خارطه الصراعات في جنوب القوقاز الا ان
صراعا سياسيا بدا دخانه ينبعث في ريفان
تشعر الحكومه هناك ان خذلت من حلفائها في
الشرق في اشاره لموسكو يقول رئيس الوزراء
الارميني ان تحالفات ارمينيا الحاليه
اثبتت انها غير مجديه لحمايه امنها
ومصالحها
ان ارمينيا تذوقت مراره الخطا الذي
اقترفته حين اعتمدت على روسيا فقط لبناء
امنها الاستراتيجي حديث باشنيان هذا انما
هو تاكيد لما يقال عن خطوات ارمينيه
للخروج من عباءه روسيا والاتجاه غربا تقيم
روسيا قاعده عسكريه لها على الحدود بين
ارمينيا وتركيا هي قاعده 102 في شمال غربي
ارمينيا ويؤمن حرس الحدود الروسي حدود
ارمينيا مع تركيا وايران تعد ارمينيا عضوا
في الاتحاد الاقتصادي الاوراسي الذي تقوده
روسيا ويمص على التكامل الاقتصادي
والسياسي بين اعضائه ارمينيا عضون ايضا في
منظمه معاهده الامن الجماعي وهي تحالف
عسكري تراسه روسيا تعد روسيا المستثمره
الرئيسيه في ارمينيا منذ عام 2015
باستثمارات بلغت اربعه مليارات دولار
يناير الماضي رفضت ارمينيا استضافه
مناورات لمنظمه معاهده الامن الجماعي
لكنها شاركت في مناورات عسكريه مع
الولايات المتحده هذا الشهر ما اثار
استياء موسكو لا يمكن النظر الى التدهور
غير المسبوق والتحول التاريخي في العلاقات
الروسيه الارمينيه بمن ان عن التجاذب
الروسي مع الغرب فليس سرا ان من يحكمون في
ريفان محسوبون على النخبه المواليه للغرب
كما انه ليس سرا توجهات فاشنيان الغربيه
وهو الذي دخل عالم السياسه صحفيا معارضا
لما وصفت بالوصايه الروسيه على ارمينيا في
مايو الماضي طرح رئيس الوزراء الارمني
احتمال انسحاب بلاده من منظمه معاهده
الامن الجماعي تراقب موسكو صدى ما حدث في
كاراباخ على نفوذها داخل يريفان يحذر وزير
الخارجيه الروسي من صعود لوبي في ارمينيا
يحاول تقويض الدور الروسي هناك لتعزيز
مصالح واشنطن وحلفائها